Indonesia's farmers are finally getting
enough water for their crops in
Indonesia water did not reach many
farming communities resulting in poor
harvests low income for farmers and food
insecurity for the country only half of
Indonesia's irrigation system was
functioning at full capacity
to fix the country's irrigation
infrastructure
the government launched its irrigation
Improvement program 2015-2025
Indonesia's Ministry of Agriculture with
funding support from the international
fund for agricultural development is
ensuring that the benefits of the
irrigation improvements reach farmers
and farming communities providing them
with better Water Services better access
to agribusiness finance and better post
Harvest handling and delivery services
but more remains to be done to address
implementation gaps and support the
ambitious decade-long program
in May 2017 ADB committed 500 million
dollars to support Indonesia's
irrigation Improvement program asean
infrastructure funds co-financing is 100
million dollars while World Banks is 28
million dollars the financing package
will support the program from 2017 to
2024 in delivering sustainable and more
productive irrigated agriculture in 74
districts it will do this by
strengthening institutional capacity for
sustainable irrigated agriculture
improving irrigation operation
maintenance and management and improving
irrigation infrastructure the project
has reached several Milestones about 4
500 water user associations 88
irrigation commissions and other
agencies are now better at managing
Water Resources together
an irrigation asset management
information system in place since
December 2019 supports the operations
and maintenance of irrigation systems
and infrastructure
as of 2023 the program has rehabilitated
about 523 000 hectares of irrigation
schemes Indonesia's farmers are now
getting more than enough water enabling
them to increase yield and ultimately
improve the country's food security
adb's financing Partnerships helping
Farmers Feed communities cities and
countries
[Music]